well guys we have made it to the sixth
and final review I'm doing in my alien
series leading up to alien covenant and
today we're going to be talking about
aliens vs. predator last time it was
just a lien vs. predator this time alien
got an upgrade to plural and predator is
still singular poor guy he needs friends
to AVP to is one of the prime examples I
use whenever people get all up in arms
about a film and a franchise that's
commonly rated are getting the pg-13
rating the last AVP was pg-13 fans went
insane this one is actually rated R and
we're going to get into why pretty soon
but it's definitely not an improvement
mmm same thing happened with die hard 4
that was pg-13 everyone went nuts
rightfully so the Die Hard series is a
very rated R series but it was kind of
entertaining it was actually an okay
movie die hard 5 went back to rated R
and was complete shit I think the
problem is is that one fans complain to
a studio that a film should be a certain
rating and they're upset about the way
it was rated the studio just thinks fans
want violence or language or nudity they
don't understand that we also want a
good story along with all the action set
pieces and the creature effects and gore
we don't just want movies that are rated
R because we like to see violence that's
not why the first two alien movies are
so good because there's blood they're
good because the stories are great and
it's well directed it has nothing to do
with the rating and once the studio can
finally understand that and realize that
it's not just about getting a certain
demographic in a theater we might
actually end up getting some good movies
until then aliens vs. predator Requiem
is a complete pile of shit the first one
I found enjoy ibly dumb like it knew
what it was it was just stupid and
whatever not a great movie at all but it
doesn't offend me
I don't even like to call this one
aliens vs. predator I like to call it
shadows versus silhouettes because you
can't see a damn fucking thing this
movie is so dark and I'm not talking
about somatically I mean you can't see a
damn thing
I thought Doom was poorly lit this movie
makes doom look like a beaming ray of
sunlight
I can tell just by looking closely at
the shots that they have really great
Alien and Predator costumes at their
disposal so why aren't they utilizing
this by showing them in their full glory
why does this entire movie look like I
turned down the brightness on my TV 2:10
so technical qualities aside what is
this movie about well at the end of the
first film spoilers if you haven't seen
the first one and we're going to get
into spoilers here as well there's a
pred a lien born an alien born from a
predator the ship that it was on crashes
to earth because it attacks the
Predators that were flying it and now we
have predators and aliens in a small
little town so in a way alien fans in
particular are finally getting a wish
they've had for a long time and that was
to see aliens on earth not just up in
space
this film proves that we're all really
dumb for wanting that because a
xenomorph walking around a small town is
just boring or maybe it's just this
fucking movie why we watch this movie I
saw something horrifying it finally
clicked with me this is the second time
I've seen this movie I saw it back when
it first came out and i rewatch it for
this review I finally realized what the
studio was trying to do this was really
their first attempt to turn Alien and
Predator into Freddy and Jason the first
ADT at least kind of felt like an alien
movie it had characters that weren't the
greatest but they seemed like they
belonged in an alien movie it had a
location that seemed like it was
suitable for the mythology of Alien and
Predator this film just takes Alien and
Predator makes it bloody and puts it in
a small town with a bunch of teenagers
that belong in a slasher film this is
the very first alien slasher film that
there's ever been and for just that
reason alone I hate everything about
this movie the entire first act of this
movie feels completely directionless
cliched characters you expect to see in
a movie like this just wander around and
happen upon Alien and Predator shit and
the film just keeps asking us over and
over again to actually give a shit about
these characters and they do nothing to
make us care I would say the most
interesting character in the movie is
probably the cop because he seems like a
nice guy who's just trying to help and
he's in the middle of this situation so
you kind of feel for him there's the her
basically dumb subplots of this guy
who's crushing on a girl from school and
he gets picked on by bullies and his
brother just so happens to be a convict
who was recently released so the cop
continues to tell this convict just
about everything that's right I mean
people are skinned because you know
predator they like to skin people and
the cop was like hey I'm going to tell
this recently released convict about
this horrific crime the cop even takes
them to crime scenes it's it's
unimaginably stupid on every level
later the cop even helps civilians break
into a gun store and steal a bunch of
guns one of them being a former convict
now I get that aliens and predators are
currently in the town and everyone's
scared but just give me a break
this screenplay can't even set up
realistic characters it just thinks okay
there's some people in a town and
they're going to fight against the
aliens because this is a living dead
part five movie or this is a Jason part
six oh this is another Halloween movie
right no Alien and Predator are two of
the most iconic alien creatures of all
time yes Michael Myers is an iconic
horror villain he was in one excellent
movie alien is totally different
predator is totally different but the
studio doesn't see that they just see
dollar signs they even took twenty
million dollars off of the budget when
compared to the first alien vs. predator
that had a much higher budget because
they just want to make money
and again the studio had no idea what
fans wanted when I said we wanted to be
rated R we don't have to see a
chestburster come out of a child we
don't have to see the pred alien lay
eggs down the throat of a woman whose
water just broke
having the knowledge that the alien eggs
are going to hatch in her stomach and
eat her fetus alive this isn't what we
watch alien for that's actually a little
disgusting and I think they went
overboard there it was just unnecessary
I didn't give a shit about anything that
was happening in this movie because the
characters are so poorly set up and the
creatures that I love and adore are also
treated like complete shit and you can't
even really see them so all of a sudden
when the film is asking us to be okay
with like really graphic and disturbing
and disgusting shit it just kind of
pissed me off this film also cannot
escape
it's
cheap look it looks like a high budgeted
fan film and it's not just the
cinematography it's the way the shots
are edited together
it's the way they flow it's the way the
sound mix is it's everything the score
even the opening and closing titles look
like Windows Movie Maker and of course
just so you know the way to make a great
movie is just to repeat lines from
former films in the franchise alright
get out hi I'm not leaving you get to
the chopper
you don't have to do this huh oh oh God
are you fucking kidding me let me show
you a scene just look at this scene and
tell me how fucking awesome it is
[Music]
wasn't that just balls out awesome now
again look at a VP two's way of
tributing it alright hi I'm not leaving
you get to the chopper you don't have to
do this on Oh
just why why I don't need this this is
exactly what I was afraid a DP one was
going to be again I'll reiterate that
movie ain't that great but it knew what
it was this movie is just shit complete
shit when our best look at the new
creature in this film is the production
photo because it's actually well lit
that's saying something
oh and at the end the government bombs
the town and a bunch of innocent adults
and children are dead but I guess we're
supposed to be happy because a couple
principal characters made it out and
there's a setup for a sequel I'm going
to give a Lian's vs predator Requiem and
F so much catharsis right now so much we
are done talking about alien films I
hope you guys really enjoyed this series
I had a great time making it the first
two are two of my favorite movies ever I
really hope you checked out the alien 3
review I did with my friend Matt Brando
we went incredibly in-depth into that
film the pre-production the early drafts
the theatrical cut the assembly cooked
it's a long video but that's something
that Matt and I would like to do every
once in a while take a film that we're
both passionate about or that we both
have differing opinions of and just
talked a long time about it and get
really in-depth I hope you guys check
out that video thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
my knives
[Music]